- Remmy, come on, let's go.
- [Narrator] It's a new
week at Doggie Do Good,
and the puppies are back on campus.
(upbeat music)
A week is an eternity
in the life of a puppy,
and if any dogs haven't been working hard
on their studies, it'll show.
Only the best pups will one
day graduate Puppy Prep.
(upbeat music)
Last week, the trainers noticed
eight month old Kaya preferred the company
of people to other dogs.
This week, it's beginning to
look like more of the same.
After a brief hello to
the people, however,
she begins to play with the other pups;
a good sign for her socialization.
The biggest change this
week is with the oldest pup;
the dog formerly known as Deacon.
Like many of the dogs here,
Deacon already has a family waiting
for him to finish training.
Graduation is never assured,
but if he passes he'll
be going to his forever
family in only two weeks.
Over the weekend, that family informed
Doggie Do Good that they want to
name their dog (sighing) Demian.
This isn't unusual.
Dogs sometimes go through several names
before getting their permanent name,
and for the pups it's actually
not that big of a deal.
The trainers begin transitioning a dog
to a new name by using both.
For instance, when they want the newly
christened Demian to
come, trainers will say:
- [Karyn] Deacon, Demian,
Deacon, Demian, come.
- [Narrator] And when the dog reacts,
they praise the dog using its new name.
After as little as a few days,
the trainers can begin
to drop the old name,
and just call for Demian.
- Good boy, good come Demian.
Demian release.
- [Narrator] After some morning exercise,
the dogs leave the paddock
for some down-stay drills.
(light music)
German shepard Tank seems distracted.
It appears Karyn has a treat.
While Kaya and Luke are only mildly
interested in the feline,
Tank can barely contain himself.
This isn't new.
During the coming months Tank will need
to work on better
suppressing his prey drive.
His future family needs to count on him
staying focused when he
encounters other animals.
The moment that trainer
Nece is distracted,
Tank makes a move,
but he never had a chance.
Karyn releases the cat, but Tank is shook.
It'll be a while before
he can regain focus,
losing valuable class time.
(cat meows)
Meanwhile, most of the younger
dogs appear to be doing well.
A frisbee may be tempting, but
these pups know it's a trick.
As for Remmy, after her tough day
at the beach last week,
Remmy needs to be on
her best behavior today.
It's not looking good.
Trainer Karyn fetches the
eight month old golden
and puts her back into down-stay.
Remmy should be growing out
of this behavior by now.
If she continues to break like this
over the next few months,
the trainers will have some difficult
conversations about her
continued enrollment.
If Remmy's in search of a roll model,
Demian's her guy.
He, too, used to have
problems staying still,
but now, even when he's not laying down,
he holds his ground.
Even when Paul claps for him,
until he hears the word release,
Demian knows to stay.
- [Paul] Demian, release.
- [Narrator] Demian knows he did well.
He has a family waiting for him,
and they're counting on this training
to help them for years to come.
One woman who's thankful
for that training is Kallie.
Kallie is blind on her right side,
and after being struck by
a car she never saw coming,
she knew getting a service
dog could save her life.
Doggie Do Good took Kallie's needs
and trained Belgian Malinois Canaan
to meet them perfectly.
Maybe you didn't notice, but all the pups
in training learned to heel
on the left side of a person.
Canaan, however, was specially trained
since a pup to walk on the right.
This way, he can move in front of Kallie
if something is about to hit her.
At 10 years old, Canaan is around
the age of retirement
for most service dogs.
When it's time for Canaan
to hang up the harness,
he'll live out the remainder of his days
loved by Callie and her
family as a non-working pet.
To get dogs like Canaan
comfortable around traffic,
the puppies need to take field
trips like the one today;
to the bus station.
Not all field trips can be to the beach.
No matter what, a new location means
another local flavor of grass to sample,
and also new challenges.
They may seem boring to us,
but buses are a common reason puppies
flunk out of service dog school.
The loud noises,
(bus hisses)
cramped spaces,
and sudden movements are all
huge challenges for a puppy.
If a dog can't become
comfortable around a bus,
there aren't many options left
for a puppy other than expulsion.
While they wait to work
with the trainers around
the buses, the pups hold
tight near some benches.
If a puppy were to break
from their down-stay
and run into traffic, it could be fatal.
Because of this risk, all of the dogs
are tied up during down-stay.
Even someone as far along in
their schooling as Deacon.
Demian. I meant Demian.
One of the first to take a
lap around the buses is Luke.
As the bus makes noises, Luke
is curious but not frightened.
This is a great reaction
from the eight month golden.
However, being calm around
the buses is only step one.
Luke still needs to be able to work.
Even though it's loud,
he keeps checking in
with the trainer to make
sure he's not missing
any commands he otherwise
wouldn't be able to hear.
One such command is alert.
Alert is triggered by an
alarm on the trainer's watch.
And while it's difficult
to make out with all
the commotion, Luke is
focused enough to hear it.
Another of Luke's special
abilities is pressure therapy.
Pressure can help calm those
with anxiety or PTSD attacks.
Since an episode can happen anywhere,
even at a bus station, Luke needs to
always be ready to spring into action.
Great work, Luke.
Meanwhile, back with
the dogs in down-stay,
trainer Paul works with
Kaya on her new skill.
Steady.
It's only been a week since she was
introduced to the command at the beach,
but she is learning fast.
The dog with the most experience
with steady is Demian.
- [Paul] Steady.
- [Narrator] Today, however, he's
practicing his get-it command.
And Karyn is not making it easy.
A slick flashlight.
A measuring cup.
Even an oversized mug.
All pose challenges but
Demian is persistent.
His ability to perform
his most complex actions
with all the distractions
of the bus station
means he's still on track
to graduate in two weeks.
Keep it up, Demian.
It's Benelli's turn by the buses.
At only six months old,
Benelli is the youngest of the puppies,
and the most likely to be frightened.
To comfort her, Paul has
brought her favorite toy.
At first, she's able to
retrieve it with no problem.
But when the loud bus starts up,
there's a noticeable change in the pup.
Benelli doesn't finish the retrieval
and begins to move away.
It doesn't take long,
though, for the puppy
to become used to the sound of the engine,
so she gets back to her drills.
Suddenly, a new noise.
(bus hisses)
Benelli drops her toy,
gets low to the ground,
and begins to retreat hard.
Her only focus is getting
away from the bus.
Paul recognizes she's
scared and immediately
tries to encourage the chocolate
lab with her favorite toy.
But Benelli doesn't respond.
Paul gets down to Benelli's
level and begins to pet her.
Even still, her only focus
is getting away from the bus.
This is a puppy completely shut down.
Her tail is tucked and
she's lost all focus.
Paul tries to bring her back online by
rewarding her for simple down commands,
but she continues to ignore her toy.
A new toy gets Benelli's
tail wagging again,
but she's still distressed.
As Benelli tries to crawl under Paul,
it becomes clear the only way to get
Benelli feeling better
will be to remove her
from any sight of the bus.
Finally away from the noises of the buses,
Benelli is soon back to her playful self.
When it's time for her
to go back to down-stay,
she's exhausted.
Hopefully this was just a
temporary setback for the lab.
If she can't learn to
face her fear of buses,
there's no way she'll
pass service dog school.
Mr. Pip, it's your turn.
The undeniable Mr. Pip has had issues
with loud noises in the past.
So if he experiences any
of the sounds Benelli did,
it could spell disaster for the Yorkie.
Right away he's reluctant,
and a treat from trainer
Karyn works only for a moment.
When she kneels down
to his level, however,
Mr. Pip discovers some courage.
Mr. Pip, this is not what
a good heel looks like.
Because it shows confidence,
something Mr. Pip has
struggled with in the past,
the trainer lets him pull ahead sometimes.
Unlike his bigger classmates,
Mr. Pip poses no threat
of pulling his future
owners into a dangerous situation.
So go ahead and tug.
Way to make your size
work for you, Mr. Pip.
Now, it's our favorite wild
card's trip by the buses, Remmy.
To everyone's surprise,
the eight month old
golden is doing well.
That is, until (bus hisses).
The noise frightens not just Remmy,
but trainer Karyn as well.
At first, it looks like a
similar situation to Benelli.
Remmy's tail is tucked and
she looks around nervously.
Unlike Benelli, however, Remmy continues
to sniff around and
engage with her trainer,
even next to the tire.
When the bus makes the noise again,
Remmy responds better,
and she continues to sniff curiously.
Still, her tail remains tucked,
even when the bus pulls away.
As she approaches a turned off second bus,
the memory of the earlier
noise has her scared.
Remmy will have to overcome this newfound
fear of tires to stay
in service dog school,
so Karyn drops treats to
build the golden's bravery.
Even though she's still nervous,
Remmy's bounced back wonderfully.
Unlike Benelli, she's stayed
by the buses the whole time;
a great sign for the young pup.
Finally, it's Kaya's turn.
Sandy, the owner of Doggie Do Good,
already has a family in mind for Kaya.
This particular placement means Kaya
would be around lots of loud noises.
That makes today's trip crucial for
the eight month old golden.
If she reacts to the loud noises
like Benelli or Remmy, it could mean
months added to her training.
Months that that family would
have to make do without her.
Right away, it looks
like Kaya's doing great.
Her tail is up and when the bus hisses,
she merely turns her head.
As the bus pulls away,
Paul congratulates her
on her calm demeanor.
Kaya knows she did a good job,
and she begins to prance with excitement.
She's gonna make some family so happy,
and I'm gonna miss her.
It's the end of a long,
loud day at the bus station.
But there's still one
more exercise in store.
Very slowly, trainer Paul brings
Benelli back to a powered down bus.
With no risk of sudden noise,
this is the safest time
for the chocolate lab
to begin overcoming her fear.
Paul gets down on her level and gives her
lots of pets, helping
the puppy to feel safe.
Eventually, Benelli walks past
the bus with relative ease.
It's going to be a long
road to bus bravery
for the chocolate lab,
but with her tail wagging
this close to a tire,
she's made a great first step.
The trainers knew the bus station would be
a challenging day, but they're proud of
the progress from all of the dogs.
For most of these pups,
there are still months of lessons ahead.
For Demian, however, there are only
two weeks until final exams.
Will he become a cautionary tale
for his younger
classmates, or does he have
what it takes to graduate Puppy Prep?
(upbeat music)